bonsoir david rigoulet roze merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
comment vous avez vécu vous cette
annonce d'une coalition allant de la
gauche à l'extrême droite
tous unis contre finalement benyamin
nétanyahou oui c'est un peu ça c'était
tsb tous sauf le bibi en quelque sorte
qui a réuni des quelque 1 constituer une
coalition assez improbable qui ne fait
pas un programme et c'est ça qui fait sa
fragilité également parce que les dés ne
sont pas jouer encore un il ya quand
même le délai de il ya le délai avec le
la knesset puisque par le président de
la knesset et un membre du likoud s'est
yariv levin
il peut faire traîner les choses pour
c'est un peu le calcul de benyamin
nétanyahou qui est un aller mais le
politique
alors c'est certainement la fin d'un
cycle en israël puisque il est là depuis
douze ans et donc il était il avait la
réputation d'être inamovible ce qui ce
qui a accéléré effectivement le les
tentatives doigt que de coalition qui
sont contre et christie's est
aujourd'hui mais en même temps c'est un
peu l'heure pour ce qui est des partis
israéliens c'est un peu le mariage de la
carpe et du lapin une certaine manière
parce que entre naftali bennett et
rapide entre l'extrême droite dont
projet la colonisation et voir
l'annexion des territoires
justement colonisés et puis le parti
centriste il ya quand même une marge
très importante et puis et puis le le
vrai les événements du bo est à mon avis
et c'est ça qui fait le caractère inédit
de la situation c'est laid c'est la
participation à la coalition du parti de
mansourah bas c'est à dire le parti des
arabes israéliens à connotation
islamiste et c'est pas négligeable et
paradoxalement c'est benyamin nétanyahou
finalement qui a fait de ce parti un
faiseur de roi alors même que par
définition il est censé le développer
logique de containement par rapport
justement aux projets qui peuvent être
ceux d'un état palestinien donc c'est
assez paradoxal alors ce gouvernement
hétéroclite est ce qu'il peut finalement
réconciliés
les israéliens et puis il favorise et
pourquoi pas également une
réconciliation interpalestinienne
oui on n'en est pas là là c'est vraiment
on est dans le l'objectif c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure ça fait pas un
programme politique
l'objectif c'était de certaines manières
de mettre de côté benyamin nétanyahou
qui qui par certains d'ailleurs le monde
du likoud les considère aujourd'hui
comme un boulet compte tenu de ses
ennuis judiciaires qui ne sont pas
réglés et voilà est ce qui explique
assez largement d'ailleurs ses
tentatives
c'est d'aucuns diront désespérée de
s'accrocher au pouvoir
mais mais il a dû il a dû des ressources
et on voit bien que là il vient faire
une réunion d'urgence de son cabinet en
sollicitant en faisant feu de tout bois
pour favoriser des défections potentiel
avant un vote de la knesset
il a sollicité les chats c'est à dire
l'organiste des colonies de d'écologie
et pour justement le soutenir donc il ya
une logique de netanyahu qui est
s'accrocher au pouvoir et de faire
exprès clac et une coalition qui
effectivement sur structurellement est
fragile mais mais le dénominateur commun
c'est elle à vizag à l'écart du premier
ministre israélien
et donc il ya beaucoup d'interrogations
pour l'instant est ce que finalement
cette coalition il ne va pas voler en
éclats par la suite si elle est validée
par à la casse est passée de problèmes à
supposer qu'elle puisse être validé par
la cne 16 qui ce qui n'est pas assuré
encore aujourd'hui mais si ça devait
être le cas de toute façon il ya une
rotation pour le poste dit ce qui est
prévu en l'occurrence de les deux
premières années pour nathalie pénètre
le parti justement de droite vers la
droite quitté d'ailleurs faut le
rappeler quand même un collaborateur
pendant longtemps de fabrique et qui a
été associé la politique de benyamin
nétanyahou un contenu de ses affinités
idéologiques on va dire et puis et puis
après le premier ministre n'en avec au
bout de deux ans le passage de relais à
élire la fidh
mais beaucoup de choses peuvent se
passer d'ici là et ce d'autant plus que
effectivement dans le cas de cette
coalition il ya le parti arabe
le parti arabe d'obédience islamiste ce
qui ce qui est assez surréaliste vu la
situation et vu vu le conflit qui vient
d'avoir lieu justement avec les
islamistes de la bande de gaza il ya ces
dernières semaines et j'ai très
rapidement sur le conflit israélo
palestinien est ce que ce nouveau
cabinet s'il est validé peu désamorcé
justement les tensions au moins un temps
c'est difficile à dire ce qui est
probable c'est que celle a suscité une
vague d'interrogations chez les
responsables politiques israéliens tous
bords confondus vraisemblablement est
notamment par le fait que d'une certaine
manière la coalition a pu voir le jour
uniquement avec le soutien d'une
certaine manière de fait de ce parti rab
islamistes et ça soulève des questions
dès lors que la solution à deux états
pareils de plus en plus lointaines et où
les dvd les éventuelles élections
poserait encore plus le problème
effectivement de justement de ce type de
coalition si d'aventuré le les partis
arabes devaient prendre une importance
plus importante
merci beaucoup à vous david rigoulet
roze rédacteur en chef de la revue
orient stratégiques spécialiste du moyen
orient